good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
thursday hope everyone's having an
amazing day i am so excited
to be joined by a highly requested
co-host she's very busy as michaela's
mom
but she made the time to come down and
sit with me and for that i'm grateful so
please welcome to the show
michaela's mom also known sometimes as
olivia my sister
hi lady everybody oh you can move your
microphone closer to you
adjust feel comfortable i mean honestly
you and jackie look so
great every day i literally could barely
sleep last night thinking about like
what i was going to wear what i was
going to do what was going to look
flattering on camera and then ultimately
i just decided like i was just going to
embrace me
do me with leggings and some sandals
yeah who am i [ __ ] kidding nobody
just um
talk into the mic like you can bring it
towards you
bring it towards you i know but i'm such
a monster i feel like it's gonna oh
things gonna fall over that's true well
thank you so much for being here i know
that being michaela's mom is
perhaps the most time-consuming job on
the planet surely
and for you to just come and sit with me
for 60 minutes while the michaela
is not too far away just like yearning
for you not to make you sad
but i really appreciate it no it's
actually really good because now is
around her morning nap time so it's like
perfect timing 10 30 a.m eastern
obviously as per usual
um but i would say that nothing gives me
greater joy than to just sit here and
have a conversation with you because we
actually do it four million times a day
via facetime and i when i was thinking
about the fact that i know
absolutely nothing going on in the world
don't really know like your hot takes on
things that are happening
but then again i don't really need to
because then i just pick up the phone
and call you and i always ask you what
you think about things so it sounds like
you're saying you don't listen to the
morning toast i listen
to like pockets and people and things
here and there
which of the episodes this week have you
listened to the guests i
tuned in for the episode with not skinny
but not fat in the beginning because i
of course live under a rock and had no
idea there was a rumor you were pregnant
so that was really exciting for me to
find out it was a tick tock rumor but
don't worry they've been debunked now
people think i have a choking fetish
because on my instagram stories this
morning my neck i have like so much
build up in my like neck wrinkles of
like spray tan and i'm actually spray
tanning tomorrow so i have to exfoliate
today
so if you you could see it's just like i
have like a little you see these lines
but like who cares people are like are
those choking bruises i'm like
girl no no and it's like
and if you think that these are choking
bruises like you're exposing yourself
because like what the hell is that even
like i don't know 100
yeah that would absolutely never come to
mind for me no never it's obviously
spray tan or like
dirt yeah it's a combination of things i
didn't shower yes anyway so i did that
and then i i
saw a lot of videos
to watch it because like the videos were
so um conclusive
but i would say that being a guest after
tyler cameron is like it's a it's a big
burden to bear but i do have to say yes
was the response to tyler cameron
overwhelming and so appreciated yes
you are such a highly requested guest
co-host the toasters love you
and if you're a mom and you want to hear
liv talk a little bit more about her
journey i think
last year we did a big patreon podcast
episode with you about your birth story
which was
kind of traumatizing we won't get into
it and then most recently we did an
update like michaela's one years old
how's life as a mom getting back to work
in a pandemic will you stay in the city
things like that
so there's two podcasts on our patreon
channel if you're looking and
me and jackie uploaded a podcast
yesterday that was so funny we read our
podcast reviews by the way i i'm
actually dying to listen to that because
i cannot wait you are brave as
hell so honestly jackie was more brave
because it's a really good idea for a
segment but you know like i take
everything
so personally and like so she was the
one who went and found the reviews that
we were going to read out loud like she
was i couldn't
i can't go down you can't like yeah i
100
understand that i mean jackie is
extremely brave so she's so strong
but you know at the end of the day it
builds character it builds
a plan you know i have i have enough
character for like 11 people
according to the podcast reviews some
people say i'm annoying rude um
so that podcast is up that's our third
episode of the month and it is i kill it
on patreon i do my home
tour i love patreon
our family and their personal lives for
the patreon because that's what they're
paying for
and they deserve it so thank you for
letting us into your home and into your
oh by the way happily i love it because
it's such a wonderful community
it is and it's just like foster such
like great funny vibes you know and i
just feel like i bring out my best self
on the patreon and that like the last
episode we did
so funny it was so funny i was like kind
of a little drunk
yeah like i only had one glass of wine
but you know it just like affects me
differently
and when they record podcasts at my
house they make me turn off the air
conditioning for the sound in the
background and like i cannot function so
i was like
sweating and semi-drunk could barely get
two words out but like really excited to
be there is kind of a [ __ ] cluster
no but it was really good and the people
loved it so head over to patreon.com
morning toast to check it out keep up
with liv and also check out the uh
podcast reviews
so today we have a great show i know you
you know what's so crazy to me because
we actually do have a lot of housewives
stories and i know that you're familiar
with the housewives
but you don't really watch anymore which
is so crazy just because like my
personal life experience was
i only knew what the housewives were
because when you lived in 777 6th avenue
you were always watching it in your
corner bedroom and i was like what is
this and
i literally got into housewives because
of you i actually used to watch it
at the apartment before that 66 madison
and i it was so crazy because it must
have been like 2011
2012 and i was like up
this was like really before social media
took off and like you were able to
really kind of understand
in the moment how things were but i was
like craving you used to read their
blogs i used
i was the biggest bravo blog reader all
their traffic came from me
bravo tv was obsessed i read every
single person's blog
i was really deep in it but i just found
it to be
very overwhelming at a point where one
basically the daily mail does a recap of
every episode with like images and what
happened and you don't necessarily have
to waste an
hour of your [ __ ] week for one
episode so if there's like three seasons
on at a time that's three hours when you
can read
a five-minute article i feel like i'm
abreast of what's going on in the
housewives world
without ever the only season i watched
was salt lake because
one you told me to you're like i think
you would really like it and it's easy
to start fresh on a new season
exactly and i also wanted to like give
it a fair chance there hasn't been a new
housewife season in such a long time i
mean like i'm talking like i watch real
housewives of miami i watch the live
reunion in the clubhouse like
i don't even think people even remember
that they did that it was the biggest
[ __ ] show of all time
i do remember it because we talk about
it once a week here on the morning test
it was
unbelievable yeah and so yeah i probably
will keep up with salt lake i'm actually
finding that
you know i need shapiro and i watch so
much tv together
and like if there is a night that he
goes out to dinner or
has plans i'm like what the hell do i
watch because i can't watch the things
that we watch together without him
without re-watching it which i find
really annoying can i recommend
something to you
absolutely i actually think you'd really
love the real housewives of potomac and
it's very easy to get into because i
think they're only on their fifth maybe
sixties
whereas like you know you have 14
seasons of oc and
it's so premium and like i actually
think zach would really like it because
there's so many outrageous moments
that's not even really about the drama
they're just like
they're really like a bunch of like
silly goofy girls okay
thank you for the recommendation it's
really and then you'll be caught up now
because the season's on and it's like
it is consistently one of the best
franchises in housewives amazing okay
yeah i'm super here for that
also i think most people know like i
actually i like like scripted dramas
yes i know i kind of just moved away
from reality tv
yeah i i don't really like it that much
anymore because i think that i
i kind of just like see through it like
the production of it all i think the
only people that ever really
did it super super well were obviously
the kardashians and i think over time
they opened up more and more and more of
their lives but also then you know chris
jenner is the producer and things are
quasi as they appear to be so at the end
of the day
thank you for the recommendation um and
i'm excited to hear what the housewives
stories are because i
really don't know how i can contribute
but i'm excited to bring my
non-housewife
perspective to the table you are
familiar with all the housewives i'm
referring to and i'm here
to give you all the information that you
need to know can't wait i love a lesson
so i think i'm ready to dive in how are
you feeling strong i'm feeling
stronger than ever okay good stronger
than yeah free brittany um okay so
olivia and i are here and we're gonna do
it you guys
don't be shy we're gonna deliver the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
okay and today's episode is brought to
you by relief band i wish jackie was
here because you know this is her
favorite sponsor as someone who
frequently gets nauseous on boats
um did you know that one out of three
americans regularly regularly suffer
from nausea
we've all experienced that horrible
feeling whether it's in the back seat of
a car staring at your phone after one
too many
um on a night out with friends or even
just the anxiety of a workday nausea can
ruin your day force us to change our
plans and in the most severe cases make
us unable to function
for those who can relate we've got good
news because you've got to check out
relief band
the number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve
and effectively prevent nausea and
vomiting associated with motion sickness
anxiety migraines
morning sickness hangover chemotherapy
so much more
the product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
and provides an all-natural long-lasting
relief with zero side effects
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients but now
through relief band it's available for
the masses
jackie suffers from nausea a lot i know
that she wears her relief vent anytime
she gets in a long car ride like over 30
minutes
and she um wears them on boats and i've
actually started to wear
i never really noticed motion sickness
from long car rides or travel
but i always got like a migraine after a
long travel day and now that i wear my
relief band
i really don't feel any sort of side
effects and i'm feeling a lot better so
i just think it's something everyone
should have in their house because you
never know like when nausea hits
oh as you're getting ready to take your
summer road trip hop on a boat or just
anxious about heading back to the office
right now relief ban has an exclusive
offer for morning toast listeners
go to reliefband.com and use the promo
code toast to receive 20
off plus free shipping and a no
questions asked 30 30-day money-back
guarantee
so head to r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com promo code toast for 20 off plus
free shipping
great gift for someone like where was
that when i had seven months of [ __ ]
morning tickets
literally literally just gained my
weight in saltines instead but get
relief bad
okay so i'm gonna start with obviously
the biggest news in my world yesterday
which was the real housewives of beverly
hills was on
and every week you know what's going on
right like with erica
of course i did watch housewife in the
hustler oh okay so la
so literally every week on real
housewives of course this is like the
center storyline
and we're learning more and more from
erica because what we know now we only
know from the tabloids and we don't know
what's true we don't but it's not true
and we're hearing it straight from
erica's mouth and honestly she's being
really open i don't know if everyone
believes her but
she's not not filming she's showing up
at ever she went to palm springs she was
in the court in the morning
palm springs at night with the girls
like she's really stepping it up like
okay opening up which i have respect for
because that's hard
when housewives go through things like
that they usually stop filming yeah but
she also needs some money if i was going
through something like that i would hide
in my house and never come out but she
also was completely financially
independent now and she doesn't need the
money from the show so
right so she dropped a couple bombshells
in the episode last night i'm not gonna
lie
it was like a little difficult to follow
she was being like a little confusing
with her story about like him in the car
but one of the bombshells was that erica
jane claims sloppy tom girardi
didn't deny cheating on her erica jane
accused her now estranged husband of
cheating on her and
not denying it on wednesday's episode of
beverly hills
erica jane told her cast mates over
dinner at kyle richard's home
that she never went through er uh tom
girardi's phone or his belongings during
their marriage
until her friend yolanda hadid split
from david foster in 2015.
erica said after yolanda divorced david
i just opened that phone and i was like
wow
okay she alleged that she found evidence
of a years-long affair
that the now disgraced lawyer was having
in the form of text messages and
pictures
erica said i knew a lot because it was
so hard to hide and you know he was
sloppy
she went on to claim that tom did not
deny being unfaithful to her during the
two-decade marriage
and so that was really interesting but
then she also went on this weird
storytelling journey
about because you know they're claiming
and i know you know this from housewife
in the hustler that he's not mentally
fit
to right physically or mentally fit to
stand trial
um and erica is kind of corroborating
that she's basically saying
and she said this for a few weeks on the
show now that he's like deteriorating in
front of her
his mental health his physical health
and a couple seasons ago
tom got into a car accident and broke
his ankle and erica now was telling us
that it was so much more than that like
he didn't just break his ankle he like
drove off a cliff and she's trying to
explain there's this ravine behind her
house
and the car went down the cliff and he
was out of the car but he got thrown
from the car
and all the ladies are like confused
because she was not being clear about
what actually happened
um but him cheating on her is it's kind
of crazy and her saying that
she had known about it for years because
after their divorce came out
all these stories were like he had a
girlfriend the judge even though he's
97 years old that's judge yeah okay but
now eric is corroborating
i have a million things to say about
this just based on what you're reading
so let's like pair it back
one is erica jane shading david foster
i don't know is she implying that david
foster cheated on right which got her to
then think like i need to look into my
own because
i i will never like put out rumors about
anybody period but like
we've always been justice for david
foster yeah like nobody
i'm irked by that that's actually a
really good point because as far as we
know
it was the lyme's disease and that whole
journey that really tore them apart
100 she was being like you know paranoid
and he wasn't being supportive so
actually a very good point right so that
makes me think one and then
two the thing about the sloppiness that
i don't
think i agree with is do you mean agree
with or believe
no no the thing about the sloppiness
that i don't believe yeah
here you have a lawyer who has been
scheisting people for 40 years plus that
nobody knew about meanwhile
he doesn't know how to hide his dick in
his pants like i'm sorry what yeah but
you know what you also have to remember
he is like in his
late late 80s or whatever and he's
trying to keep
secret text messages i'm sure the man
can barely figure out how to pick up the
phone i know but he was also keeping
like secret bank accounts and money from
people but he figured out how to do that
on his phone but not the message is from
the judge actually you know what
what i i took away from the housewife
and the hustler was like people have
known about the shastiness for years and
he actually wasn't that organized with
his
fair flandering like all these families
were confused no one knew about it but
they did so it's like i actually don't
think he was that much of a criminal
mastermind because one he got caught
and two people some of the stories they
were talking about people were on him
since like 2011.
people were just indebted to him for so
long that they let him get away with it
yes but then at the same time all those
voicemails is like
he was leaving physical proof like sound
like such a nice guy
it's literally so confusing and i'm sure
you talked about the housewife and the
hustler the only thing i will say is
like
the thing that makes this storyline so
confusing other than the fact that it's
so hard to follow and also so
mind-blowing is like when you have
danielle staub and dana wilkie as your
commentators like that's where you just
lose me like what
we said the same and it's abc produced
like you really couldn't find
anybody else no like sunny hostin who's
like a legal analyst 100
should not be in the same documentary as
dana wilkie 100
and i i thought sonny's perspective was
fabulous no and she really broke down
like the legal jargon for us in layman's
terms me and jackie when we recapped the
documentary we had a lot of positives to
say about it
but we also said the second i saw
danielle stabb sit down in that chair i
was like
this is a joke you know danielle stabbed
almost is okay if they worked at that
same club
right maybe danielle had a perspective
on her from 20 plus years ago
25 000 glasses you're just kidding me
but olivia her and danielle subs didn't
even work at the same
i know club at the same time like they
just two ships passing in the night
right but they might have overlapped
with people that work together and she
might have heard here right right
right yeah like whatever but i don't
know i'm really like struggling because
because there's so much uncertainty with
the situation yeah and honestly
last week she had a breakdown on the air
i mean not in the air on the episode she
went hiking with kyle and she just
absolutely broke down
she her entire face was covered in black
mascara black eyeliner it was
yeah yeah right you know what i mean
like it's sad but i'm so confused no but
then actually this is just another
really quick story camille grammer
shaded erika jane's crying on real
housewives of beverly hills because a
lot of people were like
they were real tears 100 but like her
mascara was running everywhere it seems
like kind of like deliberate you know
yeah so like she doesn't wear waterproof
you know right and there's actually
proof of her doing like youtube
tutorials where she says she always
wears waterproof mascara first of all
and second of all camille um grammar
who's like so irrelevant i hate to even
like
give her credibility she did tweet
something really interesting about erica
like crying with all of the black
mascara running down her face
um she basically said let me find that
tweet verbatim
um where is it can i say something about
camille while you find the tweet oh i
found it she because they went to the
bahamas in season nine
she wrote with a picture of erica with
the black mascara we filmed in the
bahamas season 9 and we were all
swimming in the water i don't remember
remember seeing erica's mascara run
after swimming underwater
just saying so a lot of people thought
the mascara was a ploy oh interesting i
mean
it very well could be i've worn like the
same mascara for like ever and sometimes
when i work out it runs and sometimes
when i cry it does and doesn't like it's
not consistent so i don't know her
situation but the thing i will say about
camille grammar is that
if all else fails for camille like she
should really become an sat tutor
because she taught us so many big words
pernicious
pernicious totally she's actually a very
eloquent well-spoken woman
like she just has a vocabulary that's
so expansive it just blows my mind
no literally i always think about that
pernicious
no it's what does that even mean and she
was like responsible for calling her the
morally corrupt
bey resnick no yeah yes yes that was
that was and she had allison dubois at
her home so you watched housewives back
then right yes i did
i actually recently went on a spiral
like where is allison dubois now
oh it's a thing yeah her instagram's
popping she's very much like still
smoking electric cigarettes and being a
fake psychic yeah
giving people their fortunes oh my god
good times
um okay well we're wishing the best for
erica i don't know we're
just confused and we want more
information we want facts and
honestly like mistakes were made here
the intent was definitely shady and just
come the f clean because like this isn't
going away here's the question me and
jackie haven't landed yet but
do you think erica knew i don't know
either but
she's really smart i can literally make
the case for both sides yes of course
he's not sharing his financial
information with her like there is a
power dynamic when you are
an older wealthier man with like
marrying a cocktail waitress for sure
but erica is a smart [ __ ] [ __ ] how
do you not know that all these
like i don't know i really i'm so torn i
know it's very very confusing and
honestly i don't think we'll ever know i
think at the end of the season people
are expecting like closure
no there won't be i don't think this is
also filmed a while ago like all of this
stuff was filmed probably
in tandem with her even before it's
christmas in the hustler
it's christmas yeah in in beverly hills
right now got it got it
all right next up in some relatable news
megan fox stopped drinking after
belligerent comments at the 2009
golden globes megan fox claims she put
down the bubbly after having a bit too
much
at the 2009 golden globes leading to her
to make quote belligerent comments
throughout the carpet
the actress 35 said she went through
multiple glasses of moe
at the notoriously boozy event where she
says she was seated with blake lively
and all three jonas brothers that sounds
like a great table
this is what you said now i don't drink
and this is why i was belligerent and i
said a bunch of [ __ ] i shouldn't have
said on the red carpet after that
i think i got in a lot of trouble for
whatever i said on the carpet at this
event
i don't remember why but i know i did
you can look that up so of course page
six looked it up
so on the red carpet megan spoke to
giuliana rancic about feeling insecure
and pointed to salma hayek and was like
i really want her boobs
and then rancic called megan fox one of
the hottest women in the business right
now
that megan fox made a joke that she's
quote a doppelganger for alan alda
before adding
i'm a man um so she went on to declare
how painfully insecure she was adding
i'm on the verge of vomiting right now
i'm so
horrified that i'm here i need to watch
this interview with uh
julia juliana then juliana asked if her
then boyfriend brian austin green was
there
and megan fox told juliana quote he
doesn't want to be my date he's a man he
has an ego i think he's probably working
on music
i don't think he cares about watching
the show oh dear god
did brian austin green ever even come
out with music that's a good enough
well honestly like can you imagine the
pitch she had i sometimes like
wake up with the biggest anxiety and i'm
definitely overthinking about like
something weird i did the night before
yeah but on a red carpet like thank
god i'm not famous like for 100 i have
so many things to say about this do we
know how old
um megan fox is 35. so oh man she's so
young
she's young but also this is 2009 if i
put my math brain on
11 years ago at least 24. like
i just think in general she's probably
nervous too yeah we put
these young girls she was even like more
of a child actor just you know with her
iconic role confessions of a teenage
drama queen and what was the one with
the also i get what i want and this
winter break
i want jordan holiday in the sun filmed
at the election
yes if you as a child didn't go to
atlanta's bahamas and like die that they
filmed that holiday in the sun does
everyone know what i'm talking about
like that we went to atlantis and we
thought we were mary kate natalie yeah
but it's just like she's thrown into
this situation
so young by the time she's 24 of course
she's drinking to cope with the years of
residual
anxiety and pressure and
i mean i just feel like kudos to her for
like sustaining in the business for
another 11 years and like
you know being in a place where she's
comfortable now sharing
i'm sure there's that sustainability has
a lot to do with her not drinking a
million percent
no i actually really think it's really
an easier can be
like i'm not saying it is or it is it
but like that's the way that some people
cope
right of course so i think then removing
that you really have to like bring your
full self all time
right now but then you're always just
celebrating so it's like she's on the
golden globes she's
24 like she wants to celebrate 100 it's
really like a very toxic 100 environment
for like a young person who might be
like insecure or new to the business
a million percent but she looks fabulous
at this event she doesn't look drunk i
mean she looks like she's living her
best life if i
say so myself do you stand her in
machine gun kelly because i do
i mean i do because i don't like know
enough about either of them
and their lives i know obviously she was
married to like brian austin green and
it seems like they were like on and off
and it was rocky for a while
i know nothing about machine gun kelly's
like personal life but
they really seem so happy together like
they are thriving
in kind of the you know kardashian
travis parker of it all yeah
these people seem really happy to be
together so like thus i'm super happy
for them
yeah no and it's also really great when
like two people um
get together and i think machine gun
kelly has one
daughter and she obviously has kids with
brian austin green and i think she was
in like such a bad place with brian
austin like they were
so tumultuous like constantly like with
their instagram drama like it was really
messy
um yeah i'm not into them i'm not into
that either but now she seems to be like
in such a better place and honestly
brian austin green is too we just
reported he's dating
sharna burgess yes from dancing with the
stars yeah
so you just like some people are just
not meant to be together forever no
totally and i think some people like
hang on to like every waking thread
because they think they're supposed to
or it's going to be like
too difficult if they leave and like
what it's going to be like but like once
you free yourself of the shackles of
your unhappiness
that's like that movie do you ever see
marriage story remind me who's in it
scarlett johansson and adam driver
netflix movie about divorce
um i don't think i watched it because i
think somebody told me it was like
depressing and unnecessary
so depressing not into that but i'm into
happy vibes but it's all about how you
go from like just being in a happy place
with someone to
when you're in the process of getting
divorced like literally despising this
person like you
you would actually kill them when you
once like used to love this person
and it's like scarlett johansson he was
so mean to her and then she finds
herself in a great place
at the end of the movie she's got like a
great thing with her career and she
found a man
and so it's like literally it's that
like the juxtaposition of being so
unhappy and then being happy it's just
so wonderful
yeah it is it's very wonderful but it's
a [ __ ] journey man divorce or life
life of being like going from a place of
happiness unhappiness but that's not
bad yeah no i'm just saying happy and
sad
at the same time one of the
main themes from our episode yesterday
where people were we were reading
podcast reviews was people ask us to
stop singing and i'm just going to say
no no
like you sing literally six 10 seconds
of a song
please it's a 60 minute episode like
just skip it if you don't like it um
we've got a little bit more celeb news
brought to you by pura vida
summer's upon us is your wardrobe ready
what better way to get back into the
carefree spirit of summer with a brand
whose apparel and accessories are all
about laid back living
and enjoying life to the fullest pura
vida is one of the coolest apparel and
accessory brands out there and giving
back has always been at the core of what
they do
piravita was started by two california
surfers who went back to costa rica and
fell in love
with the art of art and laid back
lifestyle they began partnering with
costa rican artisans
to create beautiful beaded bracelets
selling millions each year a portion of
what they make goes back to causes you
care about they partner with over 200
charities
uh worldwide they offer colorful graphic
tees crop tees hoodies one-of-a-kind
tie-dyes
they're super fun to wear to express
your personality they offer over 200
styles in their summer catalog
buttery soft 100 cotton apparel they're
also known for their beautiful handmade
bracelets that are unisex fully
adjustable and 100 waterproof
if you want to just be like a cool like
kelly kapowski gal like you need cool
bracelets necklaces
rings this summer and pura veda ones are
super affordable and they're super super
cute
so pura vida you can look good and do
good and to get 20
off your pura vida order text toast to
38817
that's toast to eight eight one seven to
get twenty percent off at pura vida
terms apply available at
purevitabracelets.com terms
you text toast to three eight eight one
seven um
kelly kapowski reference i feel like is
very interesting for you like where did
that come from i don't know i'm just
like i'm not like other girls olivia
and it's that time you learn that use me
it's about time you learn that
um all right next up and couple news i
didn't see coming but i actually really
think
could work oh what happened to my page
six
uh hello sir okay irina shake and jason
sedagas
share laughs and hugs after dinner in
new york city
funny man jason sedegas and model irina
shake were spotted at a celebratory
dinner at the hunt and fish club your
favorite restaurant olivia
in midtown on tuesday and they even
shared a friendly hug as they exited the
posh eatery
the ted lasso star joined the model and
about a dozen others for a steakhouse
that thrown by british vogue
editor-in-chief edward enfield
sources told page six siddakis was seen
in a cheery mood and we've learned he is
single
and no longer casually date casually
dating keely hassell
um he says he was never really serious
with that british model but she also
appeared in his show ted lasso
and now it's just got me thinking like
hmm
i do believe this was a friendly
encounter they're just like saying bye
to each other outside a restaurant but i
don't know the way she's smiling at him
i feel like these two have been in the
news a lot recently obviously they say
she's dating kanye
no clue if that's like still happening
he seems very busy yeah and she i mean
he
has obviously lost the war between
olivia wilde because she's like out on
boats making out with harry styles
so i just think he needs a win and i
think arena shake could be it i mean
she's stunning
can i just say something the only thing
that i care about with respect to the
story is that they were at the hunt and
fish club
such a good restaurant why don't you
tell everybody what happened to you
there what happened
i fell we fell down the stairs meeting
with
somebody i honestly
i honestly couldn't you had a bruise i
could have sued the hunting fish club
for what they did i can't believe
they're still open i'm like actually
happy to hear that you should go with
zach for like a date night definitely
it's a gorgeous restaurant
i met someone there i walked in the
restaurant and i realized i was like 10
minutes early or something
so i'm like i'll just wait outside and
so you know in new york when it's cold
outside they have like doors
outside the doors that you're like
they're supposed to capture the wind or
something
so i go outside i'm inside the
restaurant i open the main door and i'm
in this little vestibule
then i open the fake door and you would
assume like when you take a step out of
the fake door you step onto the concrete
but i didn't realize that this fake door
was elevated like
two feet in the air and it's like three
steps down but they're like so
steep like yeah i literally just took
one step out this vestibule thinking i
was gonna walk on flat land
not realizing i was in the air and i
went flying yeah i was so
embarrassed and i had so much like
physical pain
and it's in time square like near times
square so there was a thousand people
like you know everyone's like oh my god
you're okay
i'm like get the [ __ ] away from me i'm
fine but i was not fine and honestly i
had to then go sit through like a
meeting
for an hour with like this bruised hip
and i
i did say something i'm like you guys
should have a sign or something because
this is a
uh hazard and now i'm thinking i don't
know it's a fancy restaurant they're
throwing vogue parties there like i
could have had a case
i mean oh i had totally forgotten about
that oh my god it's actually
when i think hunt and fish club like the
first thing i think other than the fact
that they're good
they we also oh club we saw okay we had
one of my birthday dinners
there and they had just finished filming
real housewives of new york reunion
reunion and they all came there together
after it was like the highlight of my
life yeah that was crazy it's a fact you
know i just haven't heard about that
restaurant in so long we should have
planned a dinner
100 i'm super down but back at the story
at hand irena shake jason sedakis could
be dating could have just run into each
other this could be the start of
something new
it feels so right to be here with you
and now looking in your eyes
i just think this is something um i'd be
happy for them if it is something then i
would just be really curious as to
what's going on with kanye
yeah um but you know if people are
they're both like in similar places
having right left long-term
relationships marriages kids kids the
whole nine so it seems like a likely
pairing
um and if they're happy again you know
you know my mantra if you're happy i'm
happy
yeah no i actually just think this could
be a good pairing i agree they're
like they give me similar vibes i don't
know like when i when i read this
headline i was like oh yeah they're
dating but they're not they've never
even been linked so i just think it's
cute
cute have you gotten into it all right a
little bit more housewives news because
jill zarin is having some legal woes she
is in a
hideously unglamorous court battle over
a midwestern
rite aid stop yeah bear with me
being one of new york city's ladies who
lunch isn't all champagne at the plaza
tea sandwiches and calling lee roswell a
[ __ ]
sometimes apparently it involves going
15 long and bloody rounds over a rite
aid in something called canton ohio
page six has learned that race horse
owning hampton summering upholstery doy
and jill's aaron
is locked in a knockdown drag out battle
over a fabulously appointed yet
tastefully restrained strip mall
pharmacy
with sweeping views that take in wendy's
arby's okay this person like is making
too many jokes literally
just this isn't like you know funny or
die it's [ __ ] page six just give me
okay here's what happens
it seems that as well as leaving her oh
my god this person doesn't stop making
jokes
it seems that as well as leaving her one
imagines swaths of diamonds and strings
of pearls oh my god
stop jill's late husband bobby bought
her more than one
rite aid store we're told bobby forked
over 650 000
for the location in question but he
bought her a few which is like such a
generous like
thing like you to want to take care of
your wife like you buy her business not
just like diamonds
but according to court papers a 1.7
million dollar loan on the canton
drugstore came due
right at the beginning of the pandemic
court papers claim that due to a
bungling
property manager nobody mentioned this
to jill and so the leader central
state credit union took over the rite
aid and has since been collecting the
rent
now she says she's not being given the
opportunity to pay off the debt and take
back her beloved rite aid
so the former real housewives of new
york star is now entrenched in a
deliriously unglamorous fight to get
benadryl and ritzcracker's boutique back
in her name oh my god this
article is really bothering me she
complained um
in an affidavit that page six got i have
been caused to expend thousands of
dollars on council to resolve what
should have been a routine matter
jill declined to comment and lawyers for
the credit union and court appointed
receiver did not get back to them
um this just sucks because this was
supposed to be like a nice gift from you
know her husband and now it's like a
troublesome journey i mean two things
are i have two thoughts on this
one um kind of confused that she wasn't
given some grace like it seems like
everybody else on the planet was
pandemic
and like loans yeah and like most people
aren't even back in court and people are
doing zoom cord and all these things so
like that just seems
fishy as hell no it just seems honestly
really but i have a solution
okay rite aid needs to partner with shop
jill and ali
carry all their masks and all their
stuff and it'll be a beautiful happy
relationship you know what's so funny i
actually thought when i first read this
headline and had something to do with
like them carrying shop jail and alley
masks or
phone charms or something um but she
doesn't own the right age she owns the
property oh interesting and rite aid
rents it from her and she's not able to
collect the rent anymore because the
credit union took over because she was
late on her loan
why didn't you write the story for paige
you know this guy made it so [ __ ]
confusing
oh my gosh she basically is just like
give me my business back they took it
from her because she did not pay her
loan and she said
that the property manager who was now
been fired
never told her that the payment was due
right so they just took it and now she's
like let me just pay it
right and get back to business oh my god
insanity some people just really make
more work
it's unbelievable i feel like canton
ohio is actually like a place known for
something like something's their
hall of fame or something okay does dave
chappelle live there
ooh um he lives in ohio but i think it's
called like yellow springs or something
yes bring something you're right that
kitten in ohio is not a random whatever
this article called
no i've heard of it big something there
rock and roll hall of fame
pro football yes i would know that
because from
married to a football player yeah and
like with all the super bowl and games
it's like can't no
yeah hall of fame um the final story is
about a couple who i just am enamored
with and i know that you are too so i'm
really glad because like whenever i talk
about it with jackie she does not care
okay but i'm talking about the el
moussa's and
and their web it's like six degrees of
christina alamusa they're so
quick your last name now hack yeah
whose name is that because she was
married to ann and said who we
previously reported on monday that is
dating renee zellweger which is the
weirdest thing i think that's her
maiden maiden name from pre theresa
cause she went from christina el musa to
christina and said when i was reading
the article on monday about
aunt and said they referred to her as
christina anstead yeah so now she's
christina
hack she has a new boyfriend but she's
not married so is that her maiden name
it might be but i would it is her name i
would also say
she's the type of person that if she
wants to get a job somewhere and they do
a background check
it would not know who it is she's got a
millionaire one million names yeah she's
literally the seven husbands of tariq
of christina al-musa so and then you
know tariq
there was that weird okay and i always
talk about it that's like one of my
things like yes dennis's funeral
i always talk about tariq al-musa
because he's like living his best life
now he's dating heather ray young
they're engaged from selling sunset
they're in every magazine they're always
blowing up on tick tock he's like so
great
but people forget that he had that
incident you know what i'm talking about
with the gun
i don't know about the gun but i when i
actually think about him like
for some reason like just like anger and
yes like craziness comes to mind they
have like a lot of big blowouts that
like
feels like domestic disturbance level
they had another one yesterday
on set of their show okay so that's what
i'm talking about
and how why who when where why is
heather ray young putting up with us
i don't know like just can he control
himself around her but there's something
about christina that really sets him off
it's
actually very possible because he's
always like bursting up poor christina
for having to deal with this lunatic
okay so here's the story something is up
there tara gilmoussa flipped out at
christina hack on the set of flipper
flop last wednesday people can confirm
el muso reportedly lashed out at his
ex-wife and co-host
after he didn't like the way she
signaled to him that she and the crew
were ready to film the next segment musa
went on a verbal tirade against hack
whom he shares a daughter taylor and son
brayden five with
um he was comparing her to his fiancee
selling sunset star heather ray young
and saying that he enjoys watching her
fail
the hell enjoys watching heather ray
young fail or target or christina
must be christina because she just got
married and then she got a divorce so
that's probably deemed a failure
no i know but this article says
comparing christina to his fiancee
selling sunset star heather ray young
and saying that
he enjoys watching her fail okay
whatever that's weird this is what he
said
is this page six again with the point of
view yahoo don't even get
this this is what he said look at me
look at me
look at me it's called winning el musa
reportedly yelled at hack exclaiming
that he quote
made her and referred to her as a washed
up
loser the pair were married from 2009 to
2018 and they both found fame with the
launch of their series flip or flop on
hg
tv in 2013. they also both now have the
solo shows on the network
hacks is called christina on the coast
and tarex is called flipping 101.
they filmed nine seasons of flip or flop
together and are currently working on
season 10
and the show follows the divorce duo as
they navigate life as co-parents and
real estate experts
flipping rundown homes in california for
a profit a rep for hack did not
immediately respond to a request for
comment and hgtv had no comment
okay so i just want to say this is
horrible he sounds so crazy
like and i don't think it's like you're
not able to like
be a nut job to one person and civil to
another like i do really feel bad for
heather i think she probably gets
the brunt of his anger as well but
christine is like the the punching bag
for sure
and if you know about that incident with
the gun when he ran into the mountains
and the police had to come like this is
not a surprise
but if you see him on selling sunset and
he's like oh heather's fiance is so cute
big ring they love to make cupcakes
then you're like what i've never watched
selling sunset to be honest with you
olivia that's what you should watch it's
good okay so good so
here's my honest take i am giving myself
homework after this
i'm going home i would like to know
whose show is performing better on hgtv
right i'm just interested in the
intricacies of their business dealings
that they each have individual shows
and that they have a show together very
bizarre well that was actually really
smart of hgtv because when that whole
blow up incident happened with the gun i
was like oh my god their show is so
successful they're like a
much less successful version of chip and
joe but right they're a cornerstone of
the network for sure for sure and you
know i'm obsessed with hgtv so i was
like i wonder where
this is going yeah and
then they just carried on with the show
married and which is also like alarming
but then they gave them their own shows
which i actually think was really smart
because
if the show ends up flopping which i
think they can't go on like this forever
um then the network still has them
separately do we think like the whole
notion of flipper flop flipping out when
he's a psycho
is kind of a library there's an
undertone i don't know but that would be
funny it would be funny um i just
honestly like i just hope i feel like
christina has gotten herself into a good
place
to remove herself from this crazy
despite the fact that she has to deal
with it every now and again i know but i
hope that
heather is okay to be honest with you
because it just seems like
there's just no way in how he can
control himself on the regular if
they're saying that
he's just cast and crew because she
didn't like the way he signaled ready to
film like that's not a thing
no that's like a real sign of someone
who is abusive like triggered by
nonsense absolutely so
honestly i'm wishing the best for
christina hack and
heather ray young well so then christina
[Music]
married and announced who's now dating
renee zellweger he got divorced and now
he has a show on discovery plus like
about some [ __ ] i don't know he's like a
host
and renee zellweger went on it and now
they're dating
okay i'm waiting for my hgtv show it
seems like you guys are just giving them
out left and right what is that like
where's the hours of programming because
every time i turn it on it's reruns
from the 80s well magnolia network did
just launch like literally this week
yeah i saw that are you a chip and joe
girling
i'm into them like i follow joanna on
instagram like i i
totally get the shiplap of it all yeah
um am i did ride or die
no i'm more ride or die for pioneer
woman redrum and she's
my [ __ ] idol um but that's food
network baby and that's where i live
but they're all a part of that discovery
network you know you have discovery plus
i don't actually okay i have a couple
more questions for you before we wrap up
the episode and i can't wait to hear
them
and your nails look fabulous oh thank
you they're our sponsor one off of
today's sponsor but i'll send you i'll
give you some oh my god please cause i
just ordered some press-ons from amazon
that i was gonna put on this morning
and okay i understand i have a big
chunky fat finger but like there's no
way that people's nails are shaped this
size like i
need to return them like literally like
sliver skinny like i'm sorry a nail bed
is like a round like robust sort of
thing
this episode is brought to you by
scentbird our favorite fragrance
subscription service that gives you the
month the opportunity to shop from over
600 brands
it is a flexible subscription so you can
skip any month without penalties
senbird lets you choose a new favorite
fragrance every month to try and they
have designer brands they have indie
brands
and you get to try it for just 16 a
month you get to pick what you want to
receive so there are no surprises and
they have perfumes and colognes and a
lot of unisex options
how it works is that you choose the
perfume you want to try they'll send you
a 30 day supply
they carry top designer brands like
prada gucci versace
indie labels like the harmonist and
confessions of a rebel i actually tried
a melon and goats fragrance lovely that
now i'm like permanently subscribed on
because it's so fresh and delicious like
who needs to shower i'd love that for
you no one
all of the brands are 100 authentic they
work directly with the brands and if
you're not sure what type of set you're
looking for
you can sort and find your new fragrance
by brand style occasion season and more
um and when brands can charge 150 to
even 500
for a brand of perfume 16 a month for a
great travel friendly size
is so great and we have an exclusive
offer where you can get 30
off your first month so instead of 16
it's 11
for your first fragrance go to
centburg.com use the promo code toast
for 30
off your first month again that's
sscentbird.com for you to try your first
perfumer cologne for just 11.
sign on smell amazing sign on so olivia
before we let you go
how's michaela she's doing so great we
were gonna bring her today like
obviously not show her on the show
because
you've spoken on the patreon about how
you're just not there yet yeah or
probably
won't ever be um but we were like gonna
like ch have her chill in the stroller
but i feel like she would have been
destructive
she would have just really wanted to be
part of the action so badly that like it
would just have been super distracting
for us because she would have been like
yelling in the background kicking and
screaming and trying to bust out of her
stroller
and it is her nap time i'm like pretty
like
i would say i don't use the word strict
because like i don't think that that's
right
you're incredibly strict i am um i
adhere to my routine
you're strict i add here too just with
the timing yeah like
the kid is spoiled she's 14 months today
and she still takes two naps i don't
want to move to one nap because
then it just it's a big nap in the
middle of the day and like if you want
to do anything
go anywhere like it's impossible so i
have a great structure in place right
now and i'm not [ __ ] with it
and so what is michaela doing like what
are some milestones she's recently
reached
um she's taking some first steps which
is extremely excited she's not like
fully walking yet but if we kind of like
let her go in between like
zach and i for probably like five feet
like she'll walk to the other one so
like really exciting there
she's also taking swim lessons which is
it's so
funny because she actually like loves
being in the water she loves bath time
and like any time we've taken her in a
pool like she
adores it but as it relates to swimming
she literally just
whines the whole time and her this past
tuesday she was being crankmeister in
the pool
and then when we took her out she
started
laughing and waved to her swimming
structure
i swear to god i was like you little
faker like you're just
looking for so much attention are you
kidding me and like what
what is michaela playing with like what
are her new kind of my dress
number one toy right now are these
stackable cups they're like nesting cups
and she is
i i can't even believe like how smart
she is i know that like every
parent says that about their child but
this child she will sit on the floor for
over an hour
and stack and unstack them perfectly
when she puts one in
and it's wrong she immediately knows
it's wrong takes it out and keeps going
i actually just bought another set of
like stacking nesting cups that are like
pleny colors
just because i like wanted like more
variety but there's just
nothing like this toy that she just sits
there
legs spread cups in the middle stack
stuck away
for like literally an hour it's
unbelievable you know i have a question
because like
when i look at michaela i literally like
and this is just me being completely
objective because i would feel this way
anyway but
i think that there's literally never
been a child more stunning
thank you and like people send me
pictures of their nieces i'm like yeah
cute not excuse me kayla but cute
and i'm curious like am i under a spell
or like
we just need like a ton like i'm like
it's possible that michaela like it
would never be
like that she's like heinous but like
she's gorgeous you know what i mean
no i i do know what you mean but i'll
never be able to see her as anything
other than the most
gorgeous thing that ever was greeted but
i actually think i'm being impartial in
saying that
no no i know i feel the same way it's
like when everyone's like oh my god
she's so beautiful i'm like i know i
think so too but like
of course i have to say that but like i
really do feel that way but i think for
me it was kind of like
solidified when our pediatrician was
like she could be a gerber baby and i
was like
okay you see so many kids like you're
saying that to me like i now
feel like i'm not completely delusional
but regardless of course like
all children are beautiful no all
children are beautiful and everybody
that like you love and you're related to
like you see beauty in them and like
that's true like you see them in a way
that
you know you see that right it's like
the same way it's like
what you find attractive right like i
find zac attract if you find ben
attractive and also because like we love
them and we love their personality and
everything about them but somebody some
like
troll could be like her husband's so
ugly like how does she find him
attractive right but like i do
that's yeah no but like sometimes i
think i'm like is michaela really that
[ __ ]
i think she is i think she might be no
she's also just so good like she has
such a good
sweet soul like she never really cries
she's such a happy baby like
when we pick her up in the morning she's
always just like biggest smile on her
face
like even when she wakes up in the
morning like she just lays there
silently until we come get her and like
sometimes it's five minutes and like
sometimes it's 30 minutes because like i
want to try to get her to like sleep
later and thinking that like she lays
there and will fall back to sleep like
doesn't always happen but
yeah what do you think mckayla's going
to be when she grows up oh i don't know
i you know i think she'll be a gymnast
she can be whatever she wants to be
i i think except for a vegan the
stacking and the building like she
likes the whole notion of do you think
she'll work in like contracting
i don't know i think i could see her
like just doing something kind of like
really creative um people say the
craziest things about their kids
you [ __ ] prompted me i was joking
i'm crying we're like yeah no she's
going to be a cheerleader and a mom
who said that margo used to say when she
was a kid she was like i want to be a
cheerleader and a mom which is so sweet
and what did you use to say you
definitely want to be a gymnast
yeah or like a celebrity nailed it you
actually didn't
well i feel like you always had this
like aura about you where you were like
i'm going to be famous someday but like
you never said when i grow up i want to
be a celebrity no i never did but people
when i was like a kid i was just like so
nuts i had so much energy if you read
about it in my new york times
bestselling book
absolutely people were always like
you're going to be famous and i'm like
yeah and thank god i did because if i
didn't i would have been like really
depressed and like in college
jackie was very much like i want to be a
host of something
yes and like she used to like interview
the football team jackie says
that she's like in this job is fully
living out her dreams
absolutely and i i can attest to that i
am 200
but like her career dreams are being
fulfilled
in terms of hosting well it's so funny
because of the part that i listened to
with the not skinny banana fad episode
you guys were talking about the fact
that like really so many kids grow up
and they're like i want to be juliana
romantic and there's not enough jobs for
everyone right blah blah blah
but it's like that was jackie and i
remember like she used to say those
words like that's exactly what she
wanted to do
she ran like the network for colgate
like they had this like losery little
yeah new station you the football team
and like go to the games with like
a microphone that had a really long wire
and like yeah are you feeling about the
game today
yeah yeah literally yeah no 100 so you
just love to see people living their
dreams
absolutely olivia i have lived my dream
here with you today thank you so much
for spending the time
i know you're busy i know the toasters
really appreciate you taking time off of
work and off of being michaela's mom
to come grace us with your presents so
thank you for being here i
am thrilled to have been here this is my
first time in the new studio
so loving everything that is happening
here
love the toasters love the vibe i feel
like it was such a great episode
even with such shitty stories we tried
some days it's like what is going on in
this world i want to go to another
planet and like never come back here
again and then other days it's just like
another day like yep we made it through
i mean i feel like that is what today
was about
and tomorrow is going to be a podcast
only with jackie we're finally going to
be able to catch up
talk about all the things that went down
here today this week
i'm so glad to be back with my girl i'm
not gonna lie i'm exhausted
you worked hard doing this toast like
not by myself but like all the work by
myself like i really learn
and i have this happens every time
jackie leaves to appreciate like how
much we really share
like the workload yeah um because i have
just been
dead like i have like every single day
felt like i ran a marathon which
everyone knows i did not so yeah
thank you all for bearing with me for
being so excited about the guest co-host
i hope you've enjoyed this week i've
actually had a really really good time
and i'm so glad we got to get some
people in studio who haven't been in yet
like tyler and amanda so
no such a good range of interesting
people with such good perspectives on
like like a balance of regulars and new
people like taylor's regular you're
right taylor strucker is
a queen angel from heather i love you
guys so much so tomorrow's episode is
not video it's just podcast with jackie
and it'll be up in the morning so thank
you so much for listening to the morning
shows the millennial morning show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you yes you need to know before every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so it's spotify itunes central
public radio i have ready to cast blogs
all the places where you listen podcast
find next morning to sleep if i starve
you about a beautiful stunning and smart
we are
hope you guys have an amazing day we'll
see you tomorrow for
friday friday gotta get down on friday
bye bye everyone
you